you've been very firm since the start of
the year that the Fed would move in
September but late last week you
adjusted your timetable right we had to
make an adjustment to the call so having
that September call earlier this year
was say outlook for the Fed and the Fed
certainly has delivered but they
delivered to such an extent especially
in light of the recent market volatility
in the Chinese devaluation that now we
think they're going to continue to err
on the side of caution and wait a bit
longer yes is that what you mean is that
what change was it all about China were
there other and the market volatility so
you see a big pool back in the equity
market and this leaves fed policymakers
scratching their head if this is going
to have an impact on consumer confidence
and also business confidence and if it
does then the Fed could wait even longer
now our first glimpse of that came last
Friday with the consumer sentiment data
where we saw a six-point pullback much
more than economists were expecting that
puts it at a a 12-month low for
sentiment this week we get some data New
York Fed Empire survey philly fed a
manufacturing survey that it will
provide an early read if we're seeing
that negative feedback into the business
sector as well are any of these data
points on their own enough to influence
the Fed these are not crucial and
sufficiently crucial to steer the Fed
however they have this hesitancy and
this will only add fuel to the fire so
at this point I think they wait till
October they will reduce the dot plot so
they'll signal fewer and slower rates in
/ the next state year or two and that
will late that so that's an easing of
sorts so they'll ease before they hike
actually and I think they'll keep the
option open to hike in October and Janet
Yellen can further cement that buy
outright calling for a post-meeting
press conference at the October meeting
okay we talked earlier about China going
back to last month roiling the markets
what impact will a Fed move have on the
slowdown we're seeing in China well a
Fed move or a sequence of fed moves
would actually help the rest of the
global economy because everyone's in
this race to devalue their currency the
Chinese the Canadians the Europeans the
Japanese if the Fed is hiking rates
especially if they're hiking
aggressively that augurs for a strong
dollar and therefore
weak currencies across the board in
terms of non dollar currencies that
helps those economies but that comes at
a cost to the US and Janet Yellen
doesn't want to push the trade-weighted
dollar up even more aggressively than
the very sharp increase we've seen here
today